hola soy loren de khan academy quiero
ofrecerte un breve resumen sobre cómo
abrir cuentas para ti y para tus hijos
en khan academy también veremos cómo
encontrar contenido relevante para tus
hijos y cómo ver su progreso este vídeo
está pensado para padres con hijos de 13
años en adelante si tu hijo o hija
tienen 12 o menos te recomendamos ver
nuestro vídeo llamado
sugerencias de inicio rápido para padres
niños de 12 años o menos te recomendamos
que tu hijo y tú sigan juntos los pasos
para crear las cuentas y que elaboren en
conjunto un plan para aprender en khan
academy para empezar vayan a ese punto
khan academy punto org y pídele a tu
hijo que haga clic en regístrate en la
esquina superior derecha
en la página de registro debe poner su
fecha de nacimiento y registrarse usando
google o facebook o también puede crear
un nombre de usuario y una contraseña y
registrarse con una dirección de correo
a continuación
verán los cursos disponibles pídele que
elija uno o más los que sean de su
interés y que haga clic en continuar
ahora tu hijo ya está listo para
comenzar puede hacer click en el botón
azul de empezar para iniciar con la
primera lección o hacer clic en la
opción ver todos para navegar por todo
el curso si tu hijo no sabe bien por
dónde comenzar he aquí una sugerencia la
mayoría de los cursos de matemáticas de
khan academy incluyen un desafío de
curso que puede ayudarlo a identificar
los temas en los que requiere más
práctica y en los que está listo para
encontrar esos desafíos pídele que se
desplace hacia abajo en la página del
curso y que haga clic en comenzar el
desafío del curso los desafíos toman
normalmente entre 30 y 45 minutos y le
darán una muy buena idea de asia
de dirigir su aprendizaje puedes también
sugerirle que comience en un grado menor
al suyo o incluso que comience en jardín
de niños y vaya avanzando
si quieres supervisar el avance de tu
hijo puedes crear una cuenta de padre
visita a ese punto khan academy punto
org y haz clic en regístrate en la
esquina superior derecha en la página de
registro elige padre te puedes registrar
con google facebook o con una cuenta de
correo y crear un nombre de usuario y
una contraseña una vez que te hayas
registrado se abrirá al panel de padres
haz clic en agregar hijo después elige
mi hijo ya tiene una cuenta introduce la
dirección de correo de tu hijo y haz
clic en siguiente tu hijo recibirá una
notificación en su cuenta de khan
academy para confirmar la conexión con
tu cuenta una vez que tu hijo la acepte
actualiza el panel de padres y haz clic
en el nombre de usuario de tu hijo esto
te llevará al reporte de avance en donde
podrás ver lo que ha aprendido y cuánto
tiempo le ha llevado tu hijo también
podrá ver este reporte desde su cuenta
al hacer clic en avance en la barra de
navegación a la izquierda gracias por
ver este vídeo
esperamos que tu hijo y tú disfruten de
aprender en khan academy